oh ye and into my hole hello everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome to the
Silent House now this game is a
pixelated style horror game it's full
release came out about three months ago
and I've actually been watching it my
name is detective Gordon
I'm a narcotics investigator I've been
called in a situation that it's pretty
peculiar usually idea with drug
smuggling and abuse but this is a
different type of case altogether
there's been some type of incident at
the location I'm headed to the victims
reported seeing shadow figures and their
flesh falling off their skin at first
glance I thought I was the drug Menace
crocodile but what makes this different
is that the victims themselves weren't
reported to be in a drug-induced
psychosis when they were found just
badly screwed up whenever they were
actually introduced to it shows the same
symptoms of anthrax poisoning but the
shadow figure sightings from each of the
Vics has me curious curious about what
curious about what mr. detective man
curious about why and if I remember
correctly crocodile is that is that drug
that I think was offended out in Russia
that you inject in between your like
toes and stuff and is horrible it's got
horrifying chemicals in it and it kind
of causes your flesh to fall off but
something tells me this is going to be a
little bit different now I am eight I
have a soft spot in my heart for the
pixelated style horror games and another
horror game that I want to play in the
near future is actually I'm scared which
you may be like Oh mark you've played
that before but back in 2016 there was a
steam really re-release of I'm scared
that I want to play with knew pretty
much everything use left shift to run
now why would I need to run all right
okay so now there's something about
pixelated horror games that always I
don't know it sets a very specific
atmosphere that I can't really describe
it's obviously low-res and if you were
to objectively look at like a screenshot
of this you'd be like ah
kind of looks like garbage but it gives
that minimalistic feel you know it
doesn't need a lot to give off what it's
saying and I find that really
interesting and it brings a lot more
emphasis on the sound and the and the
moaning all of the moaning in the
hallways who's there somebody snortin up
some anthrax over here how many times
have I told you not to inject anthrax
spin between your toes my flashlight why
hello is this radioactive should I not
be standing so close to this probably
okay still don't know why my light went
out still don't know what demons stole
my light come on I just started this we
can't be moaning two minutes into a game
here I'm a detective I'm assuming
detective Castellanos hair back at it
again with that evil within by the way
is there any DLC coming out for evil
within two because I'd be very very
interested in that I am incredibly
unbelievably oh okay oh it was here the
whole time
why do ya why did he get turned off I
thought I saw a figure standing back
there but I think it's all the debris
back there that's the other thing about
pixelated horror games you never know
what you're looking at it could be death
it could be green jello on the floor
ready for eating or more likely death
okay
is that a newt oh it's a key everybody
are you happy about me I picked up key
hello this door seems to be blocked not
just locked blocked all right I'll go
this way there's good I love my little
speedy shuffle the door is now unlocked
good great why where am I
why did I come here can I go home please
this has got to be above my pay grade
okay I don't know why it's just giving
me the sense of dread like anything
could be around any other boy I mean I
imagine this is why games like Silent
Hill 2 and stuff they still hold up even
to this day and age even if they're
there their game engines are old why
does it keep turning off like that like
the games might be cold but like the
spooks and the scares they still hold up
even after all this time and I know I've
been playing I've been saying forever
that I would do a playthrough of Silent
Hill 2 and I do plan to just eventually
probably on up before I die kind of
timescale less of a in the near it I
guess oh my old friend gasps from all
the fun games that I've played am I
gonna die no huh I so ha wait I I didn't
I was too okay
ah okay the mansion is this like like an
amnesia Mountain mansion mansion
Mountain Oh
[Music]
I have no fear I feel no pain when I see
their faces I feel anger this is really
all that is left for me for the others I
don't know they might still be here I
haven't seen them for a while if there
was just some sign of life I don't
deserve this sure sure sure you don't oh
whoops alrighty then
this mansion sure does look abandoned
what a long dining table for all those
friends you don't have all the people
that you've brought here against their
will
oh god I don't like this library oh man
this does remind me of a lot of
libraries and stuff that I've seen in
indie horror games and I don't like how
many places there are for people to hide
back here I was like there'll be a storm
soon oh I wonder in red inside my head
I wonder if there'll be a storm soon his
door seems to be blocked
whoa the closet oh okay I think I jumped
inside the closet well that doesn't bode
well that means I'm gonna need to hide
oh it's locked with a mechanism is there
like a look or something that I can pull
maybe oh oh hello well that's weird
does that mean there's something on this
bookshelf
come on oh oh did I did did I do it I
thought that was just a light fixture
okay did that unlock the door maybe yes
oh the door is now unlocked great
wonderful but I don't like this circular
looking all the way that that looks like
I could play running around the rosey
with a with a monster of some sort he
please thank you yes the door is now
unlocked okay great everything's fine
this door seems to be blue ahem
what about this door this door also
seems to be blue
oh this door is not good something tells
me I shouldn't just jump headfirst into
these cabinets there might be something
in there that I don't appreciate Oh Oh
looks lovely
this place is lovely looks like someone
spent a lot of time working on this in
Minecraft someone really put a lot of
thought and effort into this mansion
yeah you can hide no I can't see [ __ ]
okay well at least I got that going for
me okay
alright then oh it's just boarded up
find something to remove this oh well
alright then I guess mr. bossman sure
okay hello oh the door okay that's a
closet did not know that was a closet
okay seems to be blocked I take it I
can't just leave oh whoa hey oh oh how
convenient an axe on the fountain I
never would have imagined that an axe
would be on the phone but okay alright I
got an axe
can I ask somebody a question
can I offer someone some Axe body spray
all right hi-yah oh I thought there was
gonna be some kind of a noise there
alright okay alright yeah I picked up a
key good wait which door was locked and
I remember if a door was locked or
blocked was this one blocked or locked
whoa it was locked okay
made it got it great where am I going I
don't like this you can hide Benny what
objects are you talking about why are
you telling me about all the places I
can hide this building is larger than I
thought I screamed myself yes it is
[Laughter]
oh no I should take that flash that's a
good idea
picked up the phone that's weird that's
weird shadows I don't like that okay so
all right okay oh boy oh boy and now I
need to know things what is happening to
me
what have I ever do wrong I don't even
know my name anymore where am I
god save me I can't endure this any
longer
yeah you and me both buddy you and me
both
all right it's got a key that's good I
don't know how easy that was supposed to
be to find easier than the other things
to find in this game I hear some voices
I'm beginning to think that that's not
just ambience that's actual or something
this door is locked with a mechanism
great this door requires a key not my
key apparently all right this one the
whole cell unlocked okay
oh boy okay ah what was lovely art you
have on the walls what is the breathing
what is the breathing what is the
doesn't that door - wait this is this
door well yeah this door just goes right
back here what's the point of having a
door there unless it's to run away from
something this door seems to be blocked
wait I didn't wait and why the wait what
wait no wait whoa whoa wait
you guys saw what I saw that door was
closed not just not just not just that
door was closed
oh and I was like I didn't close that
and then I turn around and it's open
again that's not cool
what the [ __ ] okay alright nevermind
maybe I'm getting freaked out over
something that I didn't see but I could
have sworn that I saw that that door was
[ __ ] closed
wait this wasn't here before Oh
wait a minute wait what oh ah the store
oh okay well that doesn't help me at all
what the [ __ ]
okay I guess sure let's go as sure I
don't know oh okay all right
sure I'm gonna go okay fine then his
door is now unlocked but wait a minute
that doesn't make any sense now okay I
am a little confused I don't understand
what is happening here I don't get it
doesn't make any okay no but not there
but then where does this go does it go
back up to here and if it if it doesn't
I don't understand okay righty-ho Oh
hmm okay sure we're gonna go with okay
we're gonna go with merely all right Oh
doors don't close on their own here and
do they no they don't no they don't
what am I stuck on I'm stuck on a chair
okay I don't know why you decided to do
that hi that's not the secret knock that
I know it excuse you
excuse you okay I just had this dream
that I was walking the black and slim
corridor was it the wine I definitely
had more than usual but I think it was
something else this wasn't the first
time this happened okay what happened
you mean when the corridors get all
wishy whoa looks like a steam control
panel well time to throw levers
willy-nilly I guess the machine is now
running
okay all right I'll take your word for
it how about I just what if I just barge
through the middle again is that gonna
cause a problem for me did that
mechanism unlock the other door cuz if
dead that's good if didn't then I'm four
oh okay up or down
okay can't go that way
hmm X this door seems to be blocked well
now I know if the X means what is that
white dot okay oh man I don't know why
this game is giving me the creeps like
this something about the constant
breathing on my neck and the though
finally out of here tells me on snuck
out that no and something tells me
that's a big no-no oh boy oh boy oh boy
yes something about the sound the inner
courtyard great okay wonderful
this looks positively beau oh hi why why
why hello hi Bo hi Boombah well well
whoa where hey whoa hey whoa
okay [ __ ] good [ __ ] god
good god okay
alright does that just [ __ ] oh oh okay
where am i oh my god okay you know I
just run for it just I think is the only
answer yeah run for it
oh [ __ ] well that opens the wrong way oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh oh oh key okay all right
oh okay okay okay um I don't know I
don't know I don't know he's right
behind me Paul yeah he's right okay not
that way okay all right got it nailed it
nailed it
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] look could you not do that
to me by the way
oh no oh
I can't I ran out of run what the [ __ ]
it's a chase into a maze oh [ __ ] okay
here we go again
cue the music I can't saw I can't I
can't see okay I'm dead I'm dead okay
here we go alright are ye closet wait
you'll never find me he'll never find me
in here my fool Aaron was I was just
running like crazy is he not going away
oh ho ho ho ho ho ho oh my god yeah
that's right that's right
Oh get fooled get fooled now I told you
to get fooled you're supposed to get
fooled okay all right okay all right
let's go right let's go right this time
let's go right left
Oh God oh I don't know I don't know oh I
don't know hide under something hide no
oh no this door requires a key I'm
[ __ ] I'm so [ __ ] there's no closet
chair I'm gonna run out of run steam
here okay I don't know I don't know I
don't know man I don't know it is that
it oh wait that's not door oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] me Oh
well oh come on plug it okay closet
there we are that's the good stuff
oh do you notice my flashlight good body
good friend where did he go who the [ __ ]
did he go he went ahead well that's a
problem well that's a big problem how do
i hmm
wait a minute he went ahead he he came
from a door right here yeah yes yes yes
give me something give me something good
wait ah keep there keep keep keep keep
keep oh but I know where I am I'm that
was on the other side of the maze no
what is this [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh oh fight
under a table oh alright well now I know
what to do okay friend oh okay buddy are
you uh you alright buddy
he's just tap dancing outside the closet
isn't he oh no was it safe this morning
I was cutting edges why does this happen
a stab is damn chess with my scissors
that's not good okay I don't know man
whoa no no no [ __ ] man I don't know what
I'm supposed to do with this [ __ ] I
don't know what I'm supposed to do with
this [ __ ] oh okay here he is oh [ __ ]
okay I'm under here no no no
you said I can hide under things Oh what
am I supposed to do I don't know I don't
know I don't understand I don't get it
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna to come okay okay
okay all right stage one complete this
so [ __ ] hard man yeah I'm gonna go
for it
oh ho ho ho ho-ho-ho ho ho ho-ho-ho
nailed it
oh he's not chasing me oh good good
cootie gumdrops goody goody gumdrops
okay I have a key
I have a key I don't know where this key
goes to but I have a key so I just got
take this key and try it on the doors in
here until I get one that goes I think
please please please please yes yes yes
yes where give me out oh no no give me
give me give me a key okay give me that
there's this I don't really have time
for that I don't have time for that okay
yes this door is now unlocked okay good
good
give me a bookshelf give me a bookshelf
please please oh my god give me a
bookshelf
why is nobody here where are you worried
about that right now bookshelf okay good
only it's crazy garden good okay but
that's good I got this cool okay all
right nailed it oh I did I think shadow
spooked me oh they have computers in
this day and age wonderful good good to
know good to know I can't have explored
every oh he got a key okay yeah there's
there's got to be like some reason that
I'm doing all this right there's some
investigation that I got to be going
towards I don't even remember what the
narration at the beginning of the game
said
don't even know if any of its matters
seems to be a woodshop can I steal
another axe try to like you know defend
myself the guy only has a knife I'd say
if I have an axe I have a pretty good
chance of kicking his ass
Oh more that green [ __ ] okay whatever
that is it might be driving people crazy
here
I can barely tell what anything is with
the low poly count but it's it's good in
that cuz I never know what's lurking
around any corner everything seems to be
like evil and horrible like why is this
candle sitting in a ventilation shaft
behind iron bars who lit it and who put
the candle there possible seems to be
blocked yeah it's a common theme in here
what does that say Oh whole gears wood
what this door requires a key why geez
employer report Hogue ler crook date of
birth 8 13 1962 26 years of experience
in the field of wood crafting Hagler has
born in Germany and moved to Great
Britain in 1986 employs common hog liras
really skilled with his work he has made
a lot of new furniture for the whole
mansion he's incredibly trained and can
lift a ton of heavy wood at once he's
one of our most appreciated employees
was he the one that went a little nutso
or is that the gardener okay
well please tell me please tell me this
is easy is this how it is okay alright
that's good I love it when a key cool
place is right next to where I am what
is that okay into the vent I go I guess
I don't know why I keep crawling in
these bins
what am I looking at I don't like that I
don't like that it oh okay I'm just
gonna turn around and pretend like that
never happened that never existed that
never was it's not something we deal
with here no did I go all the way back
oh no I didn't okay hog lers would I
mean hog lose would now oh hi up or down
I choose down into hell I'm already here
might as well go deeper okay doors
blocked again doors blocked alright
still going down then okay how did how
did this Mangin connect to hog lers wood
picked up a key okay I guess I got a key
that's good to know
I don't like all these stairs there has
to be a point to this right there has to
be a point to all these stairs
why would that's all right
duh no no no no no no no
no I don't want any of that
you can [ __ ] off okay
alright I'll keep crawling I think the
game knew that I liked to go through
these vents Serge is providing me with
wha oh hi hello friend how are you doing
okay are you hog ler how's your wood oh
boy oh boy
don't mind me just stop by for some good
old-fashioned Hoglund wood oh no uh-oh I
don't want to go to hog lers wood oh
shut up please
[Music]
again mr. Hogg ler you know what this
reminds me of it reminds me of cry of
fear it's got that same otherworldly
ethereal [ __ ] bhaktas of despair oh
okay alright bye mr. Hogg out of wood
today huh I'll come back tomorrow you
know what I mean though right god damn
it's been years since cry of fear all
those classics the classic horror games
I guess oh no no I meant hog lers would
I think was it I just I was just in hog
lers wood Oh the frame rate is a little
dippy okay oh that's oh it's a truck can
I use it to get out of here please
I just Ram it through please oh boy nope
okay we're just stuck in hog there's
wood forever all right what is what is
what is this supposed to be and why is
this in hog you don't take the key I
can't take the key apparently uh okay
well I guess I'm not I guess I'm not
worthy of this key
oh oh there we go I guess I'm worthy of
it oh the owner had to really think
about that one can I use this on the
truck to get out of here please
oh no okay ah frame rate better good I
don't know why
[Music]
why why oh no two frames a second okay
alright then alright I don't know I
don't get it
whenever I look in that direction sings
things go badly for me alright well then
I don't know what you want from me there
doesn't seem to be a way to go forward
here it seems to all be blocked
why oh okay didn't I just come didn't I
come from this didn't I come from this
way good night haven't I have I been
here no no I don't know I don't I don't
get it no no no no no my sense of
direction is being awful I don't know
what it is but I'm going okay
oh okay all right then
Oh are you in here now whoever you are I
don't know who you are but I don't like
you oh oh I see you ha glares at you
okay I don't know where I'm supposed to
go where where am I supposed to go I
don't know I have no sense of direction
air there's nothing to tell whoa
okay you know what that was a mistake
all right no I'm sorry about that I'm
sorry I'm sorry
I was speculating out loud I should have
been a bit more quiet use my inside
voice I'm sorry that's my fault I'm
sorry I don't know what he's doing Oh
woah woah woah woah woah woah woah woah
woah woah woah woah hug whoa huggy boy
okay I'm just gonna go this way
[Music]
okay I don't know where I don't know oh
well [ __ ] me then okay well I'd fire
well oh [ __ ] me ow ow owie I don't
understand okay well that's a problem
okay I don't get it
okay I'm gonna do the same trick I did
before and I'm gonna go the way that he
came from and hope for the best
door seems to be blocked okay I know I
hope for the best and I got the worst oh
and I've got potato frames okay I
haven't been in this vent oh ah oh I see
this vent is here for my convenience ah
I see so I've got a sneak past this guy
somehow okay nevermind back in my hole
back in my hole back in my hole back in
mile go back in my hole sir going for it
going for it going for it going for it
going for it
ohyeah ohyeah and into my hole ah you're
fast he's fast he's real fast okay I
think my chance whoa nevermind
I thought my chance would have been
coming up there but apparently not what
the [ __ ] did he just go oh boy
okay I'm going for it I'm going for it
I'm going for it I'm ho ho ho ho okay
God hole found hole I found the hole
everybody I found the hole I found the
hole everybody yes okay all right I
don't know where I'm going there's a
closet there which is good
ah uh yes no yes I don't know I don't
know man
dude I don't even know okay I don't know
where am I
I don't know where I am blood arrow that
way uh okay hmm
okay you know what fine okay oh I made
it [ __ ] oh the greenhouses all right I
don't imagine this is gonna go any
better for me better than hog lers would
did okay the people here really liked
wine didn't they is that just my
character being like boy the people here
sure do like their wine they're so fun
and they like to stab people Oh typical
drunkards those winos you know boy all
right what am I doing here all right
my name is Jimmy Blackburn my god it's
Jimmy Blackburn I have been working as a
gardener for the last 13 years about a
week ago I started noticing strange
loose nations and murderous thoughts
this is now all I can remember well
that's not much but I can't resist
I'm going now I'm going to stab someone
now I suppose Oh can't can't open that
all right well now I have to worry about
the gardener again probably a man hog
ler are gonna team up stab me in the
balls aren't they well [ __ ] em all right
well what the [ __ ] am I supposed to do
about all this I couldn't do anything
about the Whangdoodle and lever there so
oh there we go I I thought I couldn't
use it and I did turns out I'm the idiot
all right here we go
oh no okay doesn't seem to be exactly
the same but it seems to be awfully
similar which I don't like okay all
right
these plants look really strange mmm
they seem to be very marijuana
esque I'll just take some for the road
you know if I make it out of here just
want something to take the edge off no
okay Oh key in a pot all right sure all
right what is this keep go to and when
is a gardener gonna pop out of me was
that shower where's our shower in a
greenhouse it doesn't make any sense
I don't know maybe it does make sense I
don't know a lot about greenhouses so to
be frank I guess I'm talking out my ass
here I'm [ __ ] don't I am [ __ ] I'm I'm
fine
[ __ ] okay well this is the one here we
go yep oh [ __ ] wrong way already okay
well that's a bad start oh boy I don't
know where I'm going I don't know man
I did it again okay well he'll never
find me he'll never find me I'm under a
table ah [ __ ] where where where okay
right there right there right there oh
no I'm not today ah [ __ ] well let's talk
about God Jimmy Jimmy please Jimmy
Jimmy please Jimmy I don't know where to
go I don't know what to do with the key
okay all right I'm in a room with a
mechanism right okay so that's a
mechanism it said the the doors to the
shower thingies were locked with a
mechanism so I must there must be I
should just have to like throw those
levers and I don't know hope for the
best I guess
but I got to get away from this guy
first before I'm able to do that and you
know that's a problem which way you
coming Oh
okay he's coming no no no no no no no no
no no no no no here yes yes yes take my
shower yes take my shower where's my
shower oh [ __ ]
put the wrong way oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] me
okay I'm fine
maybe I don't know okay we're fine we're
fine we're fine I don't think we're fine
but we're fine okay we're fine got a key
Oh what the [ __ ]
what is it just over I believe that I am
a dead man I am a dead man that walks
around defying my own death ah I see I
am done and now I am in question land
okay wait this shouldn't be here you're
goddamn right it shouldn't be here I
shouldn't be here I should be at home
snoozing oh that's right it was all a
drug trip oh [ __ ] dude where am I going
I don't even know anymore okay this way
man this is creepy [ __ ] good more gas
give it mmm I want to breathe that deep
yeah that is the good stuff oh here we
go the blood great okay follow the blood
always a good son
uh slowly going insane do you remember I
always do
now I'll arrive soon okay who will
arrive soon who's arriving mmm I don't
like this why didn't I just come from
here well with the low-res it all looks
the same so honestly who can say I
certainly cannot okay ah good ringing
why why why why why I'm the batter I'm
being abducted by aliens okay well I'll
just close myself in there don't worry
I'll keep myself imprisoned oh boy
is there oh oh oh oh there's a narrow
gap okay alright if that makes it any
sort of sense at all which it does not
okay
where am I going on I'm just being
herded around like cattle I mean this
whole game I guess kind of if you
consider them just chasing me all around
like this maybe being herded but whoa it
changed again yes did it seems to be
mess not right mmm I don't know about
that all right where am I going
oh god it reminds me of the Reapers like
from Mass Effect 3 there wha you know
some kind of [ __ ] indoctrination
[ __ ] gave me a heart attack the
delivery you scared me
why would you do that why would you
scare me I think I'm going mad oh I'm
going so bad grumpy gosh [ __ ] god
damn it stop that you're spooking me I
don't want to be spooked I'm all skill
do this door requires a key of course it
do why
Loden it I'll just find a key is a kid
here no okey-dokey then
icky behind the well no all right why is
there no one else here why is there no
one here this door seems to be blocked
Oh
locked with a mechanism oh boy oh boy
what's with all these useless doors low
okay low aha
mail report Oh for 25 1987 time of
arrival 752 all packages are here and in
good condition
I checked the boxes as always what the
hell is that stuff you check the boxes
that doesn't seem right
you know maybe I don't know maybe
shouldn't be going through everybody's
mail maybe and what do I know
honestly I picked up a key all right so
one of the various doors that you know
exists in this weird town this key goes
to that door whatever I'll find it
I am nothing if not persistent that's
that's weird that wasn't like that that
was that like that is a right okay that
this most certainly wasn't this way
before
okay the door is now unlocked and the
mechanism has been engaged all right
that doors blocked
Obie's great good great okay why it's
it's designed to [ __ ] with me this is
designed to make me think I'm crazy
right and I'm not crazy I don't think
I'm not crazy maybe maybe I'm crazy
maybe what door was it then wait this
one I can't run anymore okay I can't run
anymore I don't get it I'm going around
in circles I'm going I'm going crazy I'm
going crazy because I think there was
doors here that weren't there before and
now they're gone but maybe they maybe
they weren't there in the first place
and maybe I actually I'm crazy and I'm
just kind of fooling myself but I
could've sworn that there was another
door that was blocked by a mechanism
somewhere here I saw it I felt it I
touched it up down here maybe what's
down here is this oh this is okay
this was definitely here before right
guys you believe me don't you you use
the button I push the button I push the
buttons guys good I push the button I
did a boy boy I pushed the buttons I
guess and now what I am good okay I can
run now again I must have just been out
of breath wait was this this wasn't
always open wait no this wasn't I didn't
know this wasn't open before that wasn't
up there so what is it what what oh okay
I'm on the other side Hey oh hi how are
you oh my god I'm not sure if this was
suicide if anyone reads this please know
that I'm not acting freely anymore don't
get me wrong I wasn't forced to kill him
but I'm not feeling right lately i
overreact in the act of slaughter and
stabbed and chopped blindly to mangle
the carcasses [ __ ] me I'm so sick
Oh Oh the book Oh the butchery ok the
butchery the butchery implies that
there's a butcher in the butchery I
don't know really strange first it were
only the boxes now the pigs start
smelling to a mix of lemon and something
else that starts irritating and knows as
soon as you smell it I really don't want
to ask anybody or I'll probably get
fired really strict rules here but if
this continues I have to do something
something right sure ok I don't know
what you're talking about
I've got the hiccups I don't know what
you're talking about
oh the smell yeah no joke about the
smell can I get another axe to chop that
down
oh ok I got the hiccups oh no this is
bad I've never I've never I don't think
I've ever had the hiccups in the middle
of a video game recording before ok bye
I think the hiccups are gone oh god
they're still here ok oh this is our day
I can't oh no oh that's horrible it's a
scary scary hiccups I've ever had
I'm fine everything's fine where am i oh
god the smell this is a closet I can
hide in why is there blood oh god the
egg ups fight right uh you think that
all the scares would spook the hiccups
out of me but no help me somebody please
help me help me send help please help me
by hitting that subscribe button ring
that bell ring a ling a ding that Bell
real hard it'll help me otherwise I'll
die for my hiccup I please the Oh Oh God
they must have been rotting in here for
ages I can tell by their rotting
carcasses nobody please oh I can't stop
the hiccups as it's too many it's do
many Maha
that's what I need I need that axe how
do I get that axe how do I get that axe
how do I get that sweet at axe okay
the door is now unlocked I don't
remember picking up a key but apparently
I did and now I'm gonna be able to get
an axe maybe I'll be on the butcher I'm
the butcher I picked up an axe great
pick it up twice I'm still grabbing a
kid I can't survive like this okay
I gotta find those doors again okay I
think they're gone I think I'm finding
they seem to be gone oh they're still
here huh Oh HAP HAP HAP HAP HAP how did
I get here we have oh [ __ ] how did I get
here
wait oh man it's a goddamn maze I don't
think it's changing on me I think I'm
just an idiot and I'm getting to stripe
Big Ups help help
follow me on instagram and help links in
my bio buy my merch Oh it'll stop my
hiccups please oh my my rock by the rock
oh boy that's a lot of breathing you
don't need to breathe them but dude but
then again I don't need a compass but I
don't know or what I don't know what I'm
going towards but but I can't run
anymore
[Applause]
not enough likes you gotta like you
gotta at that sweet light if you gonna
stop me from a cupping oh it's not
working guys
oh geez Oh God definitely not a nice
place to work what are you talking about
he seemed fine to a place to work
Oh God blood on the table maybe that was
the problem well why did I come up here
was there a key it was good something I
can't something good today there was a
key okay my instincts God to me
okay mr. sweating sweating from these
hiccups I don't think I've ever ever had
hiccups during one of my videos before
and that's astonishing
oh hi oh my I need to get out of here
he's just locked me in here he said
he'll be right back but I was the look
on his face when he said it he looks
so hungry and excited I could smell the
death of the fridges somebody help me I
don't want to die oh and now you're dead
no there's nothing I can do to help you
oh there's nothing I can do to help
myself
the door is now unlocked good you great
please
oh the butchery ah this is where so it's
gonna start chasing me I am NOT the
butcher oh [ __ ] that's the nastiest
thing I've ever seen oh boy oh no oh no
oh boy oh no no oh no I'm in trouble oh
wait I better stay away from that guy
you're goddamn right I better and I will
I'm oh no I'm just gonna better I'm
gonna do Oh God
this is my place now everyone else who
enters will regret it I'll chop it rip
end what the hell am I writing I'm crazy
please stop it please make it stop
I agree please make it stop oh I don't
know where the guy is but I'm just gonna
keep pressing forward I don't know I
don't know how to survive oh god this is
my end I'm sorry everybody but a good
run but a good let's play run by white
oh [ __ ] well [ __ ] me okay did that spook
thing comes out of me probably I hope so
I can only hope so it's definitely not
the way Oh God oh please oh not this one
okay it's this one oh it's not this one
it was this one the whole time
come on back
oh okay let's go okay all right let's do
this
they couldn't have made it any easier on
me but they I I just said oh god they're
back my hiccups we're back why are they
making Oh God it was fun
oh no I'm gonna oh please please don't
no please please oh how are they back
I was so uh that's not what I was no no
okay okay all right well I don't think
this is what I wanted to do I think I
wanted to just keep running cuz I don't
know how about I get past him
oh okay oh [ __ ] [ __ ] watch out Oh what
am I supposed to do I don't know man
ah [ __ ] I think I just got a knock OH
the hiccups help oh please
it sounds scary enough oh [ __ ] well very
[ __ ] me
BAE no I did it again [ __ ] didn't mean
to do that well apparently that just
cancelled it out all right well I guess
he's not chasing me anymore okay
easy enough huh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] no not now
okay in here I need a breather ah he
goes back okay so he goes back that way
and then I bet he comes back AK again
but I need to go left
yeah okay that gives me enough time to
get a head start again then I can raw
run full out three two one
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
yes it's freedom the gas again no well I
mean it's a problem but I guess I just
were just fine okay the butchery
if I had to go it's no it's nothing Oh
Italy it's nowhere you ever you ever
think that you're gonna just have
hiccups forever like that like the story
of the girl who just started hiccuping
one day and then they just never stop
okay this is a oh ah
Bloodgood yes great okay oh no no what
did you do to poor cherry no I can't
possibly get over this chair alright
then oh that's a that's an unpleasant
sound I don't like that sound I still
have hiccups it's an unpleasant sound Oh
what is that
okay all right I'll go drazi is it but
it's a button
all right blink I'll use the button hook
oh boy oh boy I'll use the button all
right okay well that's good
why am I using these buttons what am I
being used for here oh okay sorry that
was so boring I yawned what is happening
to my body I have no idea it's permanent
hiccups and then eventually I'm assuming
I'm just gonna keel over and die I don't
know can anyone decipher that message
like play it back backwards oh this is
right hello hello whoa what the [ __ ] was
that that was new I used the button I
don't know what it's for
I used the button oh I see you yeah you
were hard to spot but I got you ah huh
it's like a vision test
you notice the bright shiny light whoa
hey okay well I don't know about that
all right come on bring it on bring on
yeah yeah whatever with your handlebar
[ __ ] mustache
ah okay are you stabbing me are you
doing something else this is my life now
I think the game broke hang on hey hey
still got hiccups hang on okay we're
back in let's push some buttons and then
maybe let's not get stabbed by the dude
there it is okay
this will be the one alright you're not
gonna get me Oh baby oh whoa whoa okay
ah I was supposed to go that way really
[ __ ] come up
all right here we go I'm running as fast
as I can come on now
okay all right we're making progress
we're making progress what is that what
is what is that I don't know what that
is okay just gonna pass out right by we
don't have time to stop I think what are
we what do we what do we do it what are
we doing what are we doing the door door
door door door - oh okay good yes no I
don't know Oh what the [ __ ] is ABing
door okay all right good going as fast
as I can my god
[ __ ] me why does this [ __ ] happen to me
I don't know man
I I'm just a casual observer I don't
even understand what's happening the
woods Oh am I out am I out of that hell
hole
finally some fresh air ah delicious
fresh air I'm so happy about this let's
go back underground apparently but what
about the fresh air
[Music]
okay thank you obscure random German
and/or Russian man I don't know what
that's all about but time to go get more
fresh air as if there's one thing I know
I need it's a nice walk in the woods you
know what I'd love in these woods
so some crazed murderer coming to stop
me he's really that clever to go here
probably not I mean I just heard his
damn laugh from over here
alright you know what I don't like that
but I'm committed oh oh oh wow that's
not good
okay that's a problem okay all right I
didn't even know that was a lot oh
[ __ ] god
yep I'm an idiot I know I get it I'm an
idiot finally some fresh air ah now it
sounds more like laughs okay you know
I'm not gonna go that way let's just not
do that what I thought he was dead who
are we talking about what huh who who's
dead the gardener oh yeah no yeah the
gardener did Donna was dead I bought oh
that's not good um yeah so what do we
owe store seems to be blocked oh that's
oh that's even worse okay all right oh
oh wait oh oh oh oh oh oh I'm I'm
terribly sorry about that okay nothing
to be done about it I guess
sorry I didn't even realize was doing it
so it's really not that bad it's not my
fault I didn't know what I was doing The
Boathouse yes of course
The Boathouse sure let's go to the
boathouse hello
Oh Scott Bay please tell me I can escape
eh
may I may I ask op a I mean if the lake
is already infected with all that
[ __ ] then it's not really gonna do
me any harm to go sailing across it
right Oh a little low frame right here
too but that's okay why do we keep going
why are there so many places here dear
doctor stone I don't know if you've
received any calls really already but
employees talk to me because they were
concerned about the currently ongoing
lake experiment an employee once said
this to me your kind of science doesn't
even serve any kind of useful purpose
anymore god damn it I'm not willing to
inject your stupid substance into random
innocent sea creatures just to see the
horrible side effects it has on them
I honestly don't see many options other
than just getting rid of these employees
and before I forget I also wanted to
inform you about serious mutations of
the Crustacea specimens let's just say
they've grown a bit in the past week
sincerely Alan Brooks advisor and lab
observer does that mean they're gonna
grow so big that they're gonna be a
problem for me because I don't like that
at all
I don't I have to run away from a crab
when I got a angry gardener coming my
way I see I just need a god damnit scuse
me I just need to rub my cheek along
with that fish there for a little bit
before I went on my way
Aniki ok picked up a key all right what
door was locked
oh all right hey friend how you doing ok
what door was locked
it's hard to tell anymore they all look
the same and look at all the
environments change so rapidly that I
just don't know where I'm going
this one oh um that's a boy that's a big
crab Oh a big crab okay yeah grown a bit
a little bit of an understatement don't
you think there I'm not gonna have to
run away from a crab I'm not gonna have
to run away from a goddamn crab I'll run
away from a goddamn crab I don't care I
ain't scared hello Oh God I was thinking
that this van was it's gonna be full of
tiny itty-bitty crabs crawling all over
the place what is this God these whole
grounds are just enormous this door
seems to be blocked of course it does
because it's like every other door in
this goddamn game employer report Dame
Nate Dame nut matter issue [ __ ] the
formalities what the hell is this I
started my normal workday at a big task
with a repairing one of the observation
boats after sending it away I sat next
to the waterway and have lunch I almost
vomited straight into the water when I
saw a pale and rotten looking face
followed by a completely body silently
floating along the surface I don't know
where it came from but I'm not the only
one who has noticed the green glowing
streaks on the water lately trust me man
I'm not staying here for much longer
I'm gonna give them my resignation
tomorrow well it sounds like tomorrow
was a day too late for you buddy ho boy
where am I now
oh no it wouldn't be our game if it
didn't have a sewer level completely
drained the sewers yeah I guess they
tried to clean it up didn't work though
instructions for sewer pump station the
exit to the canals can only be opened
when that water is removed from them
opening them without draining the water
rules well in an instant flooding of the
Tor system the draining process requires
four pumps that are located in different
areas of the sewers to provide them the
fastest drainage possible the water from
the canals will be stored in the central
drainage basin to initiate the draining
process the pumps must be confirm
- the master pump station I don't
remember any of that
oh uh okay I just can't go back I
thought it just locked me in here for
some reason I don't know I do dat but uh
okay any crabs
all right fine man weird table why would
someone put a table in the sewer that
doesn't make any sense there's no one
gonna question that that does that makes
no sense also these doors in the sewers
that doesn't make sense either humpdy
okay well pump D is ready for draining
there's four pumps pumps II got it got
it nailed it nailed it all right
easy-peasy there's gonna be something
that I'm gonna have to run away from
isn't there I do it oh [ __ ] dips oh [ __ ]
my dick oh [ __ ] I think there's a closet
in these no please too young well I'm
guessing I'm guessing that the game is
gonna give me two freebie pumps and then
I gotta go find the other pumps and
you're those going but I ain't gonna get
more than that all right pump D all
pumped up I think pump C did pump C have
a cabinet in it that I could hide in ya
plum C as a cabinet can actually go in
there though oh yeah you know I can't
all right so if you're coming after me
you're gonna have to I can always duck
back to pump C but I'm gonna see if I
can go around maybe through that other
door and I'm gonna see where that other
door led because if it leads somewhere
that I need to go that's gonna be good
totally fine in my book totally fine
totally fine oh [ __ ] well all right well
that's a problem all right I'm in here
now nothing you can do about I don't
know how you found me but okay this
games a little tedious with these chase
scenes but that's all right that's all
right yeah you just go wander out there
you don't need to worry about me so I
found the master pump control room this
is where all the pumps go to I gotta
come back here after I get pumps a and B
which shouldn't be too much of a problem
oh no come on [ __ ] why was he right god
[ __ ] damnit [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
nah I'm under a table you'll never find
me oh [ __ ] it worked I can't believe
that worked
always come back well this is a problem
what if he oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no
oh no oh no if he well if he just stays
here then I'm kind of bonded [ __ ]
hell
going for it ah oh [ __ ] oh okay
why I can't believe it worked [ __ ] I
think that's the last door this is
Lester there's got to be right gotta me
please be oh no no no no no no no no oh
what the [ __ ] okay well I'm out of
sprint I think Oh what about this door
yes yes please yes yes yes I found it
okay it was around the corner that's
what it was it was around the corner
okay so now if I just hit these up wait
wait he's coming down the only that's
the only way out
maybe if I maybe if i tuck into the the
tiny indentation no he'd find me oh [ __ ]
it is not gonna work
holy worked okay all right good I've got
this I've got this this is it here we go
here we go we're going okay we're going
we're going we're going we're going
huh all right all right all right yours
I know he probably doesn't come in here
I'm just double-checking okay yes yes
yes yes yes Papa okay finally I'm in the
canals and they're being drained okay
good good good good good
please tell me I'm making some progress
on getting the hell out of here
doors him to be the door that's not good
okay well that's drained indeed a lot of
barbed wire going on here seems to be a
lot different than when I first came to
this mansion seems to be a lot more
industrial than I remember okay what's
with the somber music there's something
to be sad about oh that's that's not
good no bueno there oh okay
barbed wire yes yeah the music
definitely took a mood shift why are we
sad now oh I don't know what kind of
mood this is precursor to a dubstep
party I don't know oh I'm fine oh no
it's waters right I'm not fine I I'm
definitely not fine
oh god my ears [ __ ] hell
good god well if I hadn't just been
running for ten years I'd be able to run
some more I'm not gonna make this discus
I can't run uh-oh ladder that's perfect
no okay [ __ ] I just
I had just been running for eons and a
day at goddamnit
oh I can't run because I'm waist-deep in
it okay I see I see
ah but strafe running works ah Risa
oh good we finally the whoa we finally
made it to the research station I don't
know what I'm gonna find here other than
yup this this plant really drives people
crazy m-- - uh this seem to not do okay
as human beings after they ingest and/or
are injected with this substance alright
[Music]
something tells me I've probably already
breathed in a lethal dose alright
results by Jane Beckman
Beckham substance B hey Derek canary
insists the IV was exposed to substance
B for 24 hours after five hours several
bloods along the vines became visible
after nineteen hours the Bloods had
developed into fully grown blossoms and
mainly red and yellow colors of an on
some of the plants the effect completely
failed to show off test results the
experiment mostly went as we expected it
to the intended effect appeared but
still needs some improvement but I think
we are ready to involve larger kinds of
test subjects yeah probably not judging
by the way things went where am I going
what am I gonna run away from next what
are you gonna throw at me please what
fresh hell oh well this isn't a way out
well why not come in here other than
took whoa okay well I guess I'm up on my
feet then am I supposed to break those
or something the mines are supposed to
bathe them the chemicals a little bit
more than I already have
hmm all right this games longer than I
thought too III didn't expect it to be
this involved oh that's good radiation
in my face okay good I mean there's been
a lot of trial and error especially on
the chase scenes but yeah it's been
going on a lot longer than I intended
yeah I thought it was gonna be like an
hour maybe 45 minute game but we're
lock-in the two-hour mark now that it's
been bad it's just been more than I was
anticipating Oh No why why why why would
you do that no why would you do that why
why oh no don't do it please please you
know how much I love and feel safe in
these okay all right I'm gonna pretend
like that never happened because as far
as I'm concerned that never did because
it'll never affect me negatively okay
looks about to feel was about to be like
oh no got silent ah though the welcoming
thumps of the timpani back there oh okay
Janne Beckham oh no no no no no no no no
no no oh what is that
what am I looking at I don't even know
what I'm looking at what am I looking at
I can't move whoa
that's not good what if that is and
whatever's happening there that's
probably that's probably not good but
you know I need not involve me I I don't
think I need to be a part of whatever
that is Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
detective investigator yeah
this has a much bigger facility
[Applause]
strong okay
my name is dr. mark stone I am the
founder of the organization the leading
scientist for researching on substance B
that information anyways
[Applause]
to test a substance on but no but we
tread sea creatures and especially
crustaceans first
[Music]
no no no I won't I don't think I will I
don't think I will and I don't think I
want to I don't consent to this I didn't
sign any forms off it's just the gas
I've been breathing this in since the
day I got here ah it cleanses my pores
at this point it's real nice I use it to
just relax and meditate so yeah I'm
falling asleep it's all good it's all
good
oh boy what what what else what else
could you do to me what else could you
do to me what could you do to me what
could you do to me that you haven't
already done please oh I'm not moving
[Music]
what what how did you what the [ __ ] are
you doing
um okay did I do that
[Music]
oh yay freedom yay thank you so much for
playing the Silent House oh you're
welcome I don't understand how that
ending is I don't understand what
happened I got injected with the formula
but maybe I've gotten already a nice
dose of it as it was but then towards
the end of it like okay so they were
doing some research into a substance
that was causing mutations in various
life forms and they were trying to
replicate some beneficial results but
all it did was drive people crazy I
don't know what else I've been I don't
know what happened to me but I
definitely killed that dude and now I'm
in some kind of peaceful Wonderland
bright sunny day but anyway that was the
Silent House I got frustrated a few
times just because I was tired of going
back and forth with like being chased
and then trying to lose them and then
the mechanics not being clear but
overall for a game that was made by us
tiny team maybe even one person this is
really good it was very scary like it
really got to me especially in the very
beginning of the game when I didn't know
what I was getting into but it really
got to me it was super spooky and I
liked it a lot so if you guys want to
play this for yourself or send some love
to the developers I'll put the link in
the description below please extend a
warm welcome to them and thank them for
me for such a cool game and thank you
all so much for watching let me know
what you thought down in the comments
below and as always and we'll see you
[Music]